We're in Tuscany, about to learn how to make gelato and pizza from scratch...
...with ingredients from the vegetable garden behind me here at the local farmhouse.
This is such a beautiful vegetable garden.
We're picking bits and pieces out of here...
...that we're gonna use later on in our cooking for the gelato and the pizza.
Today, we have pizza and gelato scoop.
I will show you how to prepare the pizza...
...and let you prepare your own pizza.
And you'll fly the dough.
Yeah.
Go!
That's it!
These are the zucchini flowers from earlier down in the garden.
It's like arts and crafts, pizza style.
Smells so good.
So, the first step in preparing your gelato is choosing the ingredients.
Today, I've chosen hazelnut as my flavor for gelato.
These are some pretty simple ingredients:...
...milk, cream, sugar and, of course, hazelnuts.
Wow! It's like a science experiment.
Oh, wow! And there's our gelato.
Can I lick the spoon?
No!
And then in the end, you can enjoy your pizza and your gelato,...
...and drink beer or wine as you like.